COLT MCANLIS: Hey, everybody.
Colt McAnlis here.
I want to take some time from
the San Francisco airport
to thank everyone on Reddit
for the amazing support
for the Alton Brown
comments and posts
for the Android Performance
Patterns show and Compressor
Head, as well.
Funny note-- we were
actually finishing up
filming some of the last
episodes of Android Performance
Patterns season two this week
when one of the engineers
burst in yesterday and let
us know that we'd actually
reached the top of the
programming board on Reddit.
So after reading
all of the thoughts
and all the comments and all
the positive feedback there,
I really just wanted
to make a video
and thank everyone so much
for the support and, really,
the positive feedback.
That's amazing to get
for this type of content.
So if you're
interested, season two
is actually going to
be coming out soon
in the next couple of weeks.
If you want to follow
along with that,
make sure you follow the
Google Developers and Android
Developers account on YouTube.
And season three of Android
Performance Patterns
is currently in
scripting, so if there's
anything you want to hear
talked about, any ideas
that you want us
to cover, make sure
you leave comments
on this video,
and I'll do everything
I can to make sure
that we cover that for you.
So I got to get going, but thank
you, again, everyone, so much
on the Reddit community for the
support and the great feedback.
Keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember,
perf matters.